This is gallium.
It's a metal but it has
a melting point of 29.76 degrees Celcius.
Which means that it will melt in your hand
to produce a beautiful silvery liquid like. this
Unlike mercury, which is toxic,
gallium is completely safe
which means you can do
some pretty amazing stuff with it.
Like mold it into shapes...
or just swirl it around for hours in slow motion
Which we did.
A really cool thing we can
do with gallium involves aluminium
I've got an empty aluminium drinks can,
which we have sanded all the paint off of,
and some liquid gallium here
Now applying a small drop of this to the
aluminium
is gonna do something really interesting.
Onto the can and then
because there'll be a layer of aluminium
oxide on the top
just scratch away a little bit...
Now we just need to leave the
gallium on there for a few hours
but you can see already that the gallium is
tarnishing
from a silvery colour to  blackish gray coloor
So this is our can that we left overnight
and you can see that the gallium
has spread through the aluminium
and watch what happens
when I put my finger through it
So it's incredibly weak it's a really weird feeling
it's it's almost like there's
nothing there at all, it just crumbles to
something that feels a bit like ash in
between my fingers
And of course we also wanted to give
this a try with a full can
just to see what would happen...
[CAN EXPLODES]
Wow!
[LAUGHTER]
That way really fast right?
So we've just sprayed gallium
all over our faces and the camera
and exploded this because
it took way less time than we thought it
was going to.
I thought that might take
up to an hour the quickest and it took
seconds there
and it's just exploded in our faces,
really amazingly torn open the can as well.
Exciting and just a little bit frightening.
So what's going on here to change
aluminium from something
relatively strong that can be
bent and deformed without breaking
to something much weaker and brittle even?
Well contrary to what you might think,
it's not a chemical reaction.
The liquid gallium is actually
physically penetrating through the aluminium.
It's a process called liquid metal embrittlement.
This is how it works.
As a solid aluminium has a crystal structure.
Its atoms are arranged in a rigid lattice like this,
it's very ordered and the bonds
between the atoms are very strong.
As in all metals, the outer electrons
of the aluminium atoms
aren't bound to one atom, but instead can
move freely within the lattice
It's the attraction between the positive
aluminium ions
and the free moving negative electrons
that bonds the crystal together.
But the solid aluminium isn't
just one huge crystal.
We can represent the structure in two dimensions.
It's actually made up of many
tiny crystals in different orientations
called grains, between the grains we have
grain boundaries
there's still some bonding between the grains
but it's not as strong as
within the grains themselves
When we introduced just a
small amount of gallium
onto the surface of the can,
because the gallium is a liquid
it can penetrate very rapidly
into the aluminium grain boundaries
and once it's there it gets in the way
of the bonding between those grains
This makes it much easier
to break the grains apart,
because now instead of pulling on
strong aluminium bonds
you're pulling on the weak bonds
between the liquid gallium atoms
So it doesn't take much
for the aluminium to crumble apart
[LAUGHTER]
That's it for this video, thanks for
watching
One last thing a bit of a mystery that we had actually,
we showed you one of the cans exploding
as we applied some gallium to it earlier
but to be truthful that was the only time
we got a can to explode
every other time we tried
we just got a weak little stream
of drink squeezing out of the can
Ah what?
That was not it again. That was it again!
So if you've got any ideas what was happening
that was different that one
time the can exploded please let us know
down in the comments
If you like these videos, the Ri is now on Patreon
so click the link above if you'd like to support
our work
and you'll get access to videos early on
and some digital freebies. Thanks!